So far, error handling has come in
the form of .catches like this one.
But there are actually other ways.
These two chunks of code
are actually equivalent.
.catch is just shorthand for .then
undefined and then a rejection function.
Notice how, this then is
actually is taking two arguments.
The full function signature for
then is actually this.
In this form,
if any previous promise is rejected,
the reject function gets called.
If they resolve,
then the resolve function get's called.
If there is no resolve function and
the promise before this then resolves,
then this then gets skipped over and
the next then is called.
In all cases,
as soon as a promise rejects,
then the JavaScript engine skips to
the next reject function in the chain,
whether that's in a .catch or a .then.
So that means an error
here in this promise or
here in this promise,
both get caught by this cache.
Both methods .catch and .then with
two callbacks work equally well.
However, it's actually recommended
that you use .catch when you can,
because .catch is just
easier to read and
write than a second .then call
back which can be hard to spot.
In fact, you might not have
even noticed it right here.
That being said,
there is a major difference
in the execution order between
.catch and a second call back.
Notice that you cannot call
both the resolve function and
the reject function if they're
part of the same .then.
Only one or the other, or
neither will get called.
If something goes wrong with the resolve
function, you'll need another .catch or
another .then,
farther down the line to catch it.
But if you have .then and then a .catch.
Each with their own resolve or
reject function.
Both of them can possibly get called.
And finally,
I want to make one more subtle point.
It's also worth noting that
it isn't necessarily true,
that passing a value to resolve
means that the promise succeeded.
This is a subtle point.
So go see Jake Archibald's blog
post in the instructor notes for
more information.
In the next quiz, you'll be thinking
through the flow of a chain of promises
using different formats.